I was going to say as well like in I
think as you were making divorce court
or a divorce yes a major major reason
why I see that women are you know men
have pretty much stayed the same in
terms of very
not simple and derogative way but
there's very basic stuff you know not
have high standards of what a woman
should bring but um
women have gone to universities got
degrees and you know all that stuff
in in recent years so that has been a
major factor in them thinking oh you
know what I can do better and that's
where hypergamy comes in
women have never had the skills like to
this level ever before and where men
have kind of stayed the same you know
they're they're the Breadwinners but now
when the woman can out earn him
naturally she'll be like oh I could do
better than him like what can he offer
me and